AIs beat humans at Go, generate text and even art!
Are AIs of today already smarter than you?
The short answer is…
no.
While you are a general intelligence, capable of
making analogies and quickly
adapting to new situations,
current AI’s are highly specialized, but
have trouble with mundane situations.
Even worse, they solve problems in unrobust ways:
Imagine an AI with the goal of telling the
exact time of the mailman’s daily arrival.
The AI learns his behavior by
observing him for two weeks.
When finally ready to make predictions, it
notifies you that the mailman has arrived!
But you see no mailman, only
Ms. Coffee Bean playing outside.
Why did the AI make this mistake?
Because in the two weeks of
training, the appearance of
the mailman was correlated with
Ms. Coffee Bean’s appearance!
Such mistakes are characteristic for today’s AIs
that are overly complicated correlation detectors.
Think about this the next
time you see an AI headline.